[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشخلي
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه اللقطات من والتي تشهد
اجواء الحرب منذ عام تصعيد الميداني ومناخ
تصعيدي متزايد باتي يتجاوز حدود البلاد
ومن مجلس الامن في نيويورك اوكرانيا حاضره
بتفاصيل الحرب حيث تعقد جلسه خاصه في هذه
اللحظات
وفي مواضيع الحصاد الليله
تونس على وقع اتساع ازمه الاعتقالات
والاستدعاءات السلطات تخضع زعيمه حركه
النهضه لتحقيق جديد تهمون بالارهاب ضد
الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري وعضوا في
جبهه الخلاص رئيس جبهه الخلاص يقول
للجزيره ان حمله الاعتقالات تتوسع وتعم كل
الاوساط والرئيس سعيد يقول انه يعمل على
انقاذ الدوله وانه لا تراجع الى الوراء
منسق الامم المتحده لعمليه السلام يبحث في
غزه جهود خفض التوتر بعد تصعيد وقصف
اسرائيلي فجر اليوم
وعقد اليوم الدامي في نابلس اضراب مفتوح
في القدس والضفه والقطاع تمديدا بما وصفت
بالمجزره
اوكرانيا عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب
تلويح من بوت بالترسانه النوويه تزامنا مع
اعلانه العزم على نشر صواريخ
عابره القارات زلنسيكيه تعهدوا بتحقيق
النصر واشنطن تواصل نهج العقوبات باعلان
حزمه جديده غدا وتقول ان نهايه الحرب
ستضمن عدم اقدام موسكو على ما فعلته مره
اخرى
على وقع اتهامات من الولايات المتحده وحلف
النيتو بنيتها دعم روسيا باسلحه فتاكه
الصين تقول انها ستعلن قريبا مبادره
لتسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا في الاتهامات
الغربيه والرئيس الاوكراني يرحب بانخراطها
في محادثات السلام
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا استمرار تداعيات المشهد الذي عاشته
مدينه نابلس في الاراضي الفلسطينيه اليوم
شهدت مدن الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه اضرابا
وحدادا على من قتلتهم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي امس كيف يتوقع ان تؤثر على
المشهد بعدما اعلن من قبل عن تفاهمات بين
السلطه والحكومه الاسرائيليه بوساطه
امريكيه لاستطلاع ارائكم بهذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي هل ستؤثر
التطورات في الضفه الغربيه على ما اعلن من
تفاهمات بين السلطه والحكومه الاسرائيليه
النتيجه جاءت على النحو الاتي
31% قالوا نعم ستتاثر هذه التفاهمات فيما
قال
69% ان هذه التفاهمات لن تتاثر
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصتنا الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
تتابعون ايضا
في تركيا هز جديده بقوه خمس درجات تضرب
هاتاي والسلطات تهدم بلده كامله بسبب
تدهور تضرر مبانيها
كما تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
تمديد اعتقال صحفي شبكه الجزيره دون
محاكمه في مصر وتنديد حقوقي بتجديد حبسهم
دون سند قانوني
تستمر في تونس حمله الاعتقالات والايقافات
التي بداتها السلطات هذا الشهر واستهدفت
عددا من السياسيين والاعلاميين والمحامين
بينهم رئيس الحزب الجمهوري عصام الشابي
والقياديه في جبهه الخلاص المعارضه شيماء
عيسى رئيسه جبهه الخلاص قال للجزيره ان
حمله الاعتقالات تتسع وتعم كل الاوساط
وانها لم تعد تقتصر على السياسيين اما
الرئيس قيس سعيد فقال خلال لقاء مع وزير
الداخليه انه لا تراجع الى الوراء ابدا
وانه يعمل على ما سماه انقاذ الدوله
التونسيه
حمله الاعتقالات الامنيه والملاحقات
القضائيه استهدفت رئيس الحزب الجمهوريه
عصام الشابي والقياديه البارزه في جبهه
الخلاص الوطني شيماء عيسى لتتسع القائمه
التي ضمت سياسيين وحقوقيين ومحامينا
ونقابيين ملاحقات اعتبرتها المعارضه تصفيه
حساب من الرئيس قيس سعيد مع خصومه
السياسيين ومنتقديه من جميع الاطياف
المدنيه والنقابيه
كل هذه الحمله تستهدف قوى الديمقراطيه
القوات المناهضه للانقلاب القوى اللي قالت
لقيس سعيد لا للحكم الفردي لا للاستبداد
ولا للعوده لما قبل الثوره لكن الرئيس قيس
سعيد يؤكد ان الايقافات تاتي على خلفيه
تامر المعتقلين على امن الدوله الداخلي
والخارجي وانها تتم دون انتهاك للحقوق
والحريات
مع الحرصي على استقلاليه القضاء هي حرب
تحرير وطني ولابد من تحرير الوطن من كل
هؤلاء الادران
الشعب التونسي الى الوراء ونحن نحن
الامانه في حين هم ياكلوا في الواقع كامل
الفكر الاجرامي لتحطيم الدوله ولضرب الوطن
وفي ظل ما تشهده البلاد تثار اسئله حول
حظوظ نجاح اي مبادره لحوار وطني ينزع فتيل
الازمه او يخفف حاله الاحتقان لا يوجد
حوار الحوار المطلوب هو حوار يجمع المجتمع
التونسي مع بعضه البعض بكل مكونات وقوات
سياسيه والحيه والمجتمعيه حول اي تونس
نريد هل هي تونس العنصريه القمعيه التي
تعود بنا الى قرون الماضيه حيث يحكم الملك
ونحن نطيع هي تونس تنهض من رمادها وتؤسس
لدوله دوله القانون والحريات ح تحرير
الوطني كما يصفها سعيد جبهت بانتقادات
داخليه وخارجيه والخيط الناظم بين هذه
التفاعلات التعبير عن القلق والانشغال
والدعوه الى الحوار سدب عليك الجزيره تونس
كما قرر قاضي التحقيق بسكنه الحرس الوطني
الابقاء على رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي في حاله سراح وقد مثل الغنوشي
امام محقق امني في سكنه الحرس الوطني في
العوينه في العاصمه التونسيه للاستماع
اليه في قضيه جديده رفعها ضده احد
الامنيين وكانت حركه النهضه قالت في وقت
سابق ان الملاحقات التي تتم في حق رئيسها
تندرج في اطار التصفيه السياسيه لمعارضي
الانقلاب
من تونس محمد امين الجربي عضو تحالف احرار
هو معنى الان وكذلك ينضم الينا سمير ديلو
المحامي وعضو اللجنه التنفيذيه لجبهه
الخلاص الوطني اهلا بكما في الحصاد
وابدا معك اذن السيد سمير ديلو هذه
الخطوات التي الان بدات تطال ليس فقط
المعارضين السياسيين وانما اي من يعارض
سواء كان صحفيا سواء كان مدنيا ناشطا الكل
معرضون لهذه الموجه كيف تترجمنا
كان الجميع يعلم ان السيد قيس سعيد لا
يؤمن بالاجسام الوسيطه وقد عبر عن ذلك حتى
قبل توليه الرئاسه ما نشهده اليوم ليس
مفاجئا هو تجسيم هذه الرؤيه وهذه القناعات
بالسعي الى محو كل الاجسام الوسيطه من
الوجود سواء كانت مجموعات او جماعات او
جمعيات او منظمات نقبيه وكل مكونات
المجتمع المدني ما نشهده من حمله كما
تفضلتي استاذه ليلى لما تطل فقط السياسيين
لما قالت كل الذين لا يساندون مسانده
المطلقه السيد سعيد وهم الذين يسميهم
الوطنيين الصادقين اما الباقي فهو يطلق
عليهم كل النوت المشينه وكل اسماء الحشرات
والزواحف وتطور الامر الى حد اعتبارهم
خلايا سرطانيه يجب استهدافها بالسلاح
الكيماوي هو يقول
بالاشعه ام بالكيميائي في اي مرحله نحن
السيد
محمد امين الجربي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
قبل الخوف في اي اي تصنيف او او اي ما هي
الاشياء اولا فلنتحدث
هم في تلك القضايا نحن لا نمتلك اي معلومه
في ننتظر الى حد الان ختمه ابحاث الاوليه
هناك اي قاضي تحقيق في تونس لا يحيل شخصيه
اعتباريه الا بشبهات تنتقي الى قرائن
ولنظر قبل ان نتحدث قبل ذلك ان المحاسبه
هي مقلب شعبي اما هناك قبل الرئيس كانت
هناك عشريه كامله كانت فيها اغتيالان كان
فيها دور اقتصادي كان فيها تقسيم الى
المجتمع وقبل ذلك كان هناك ملاعب بقوط
التونسيين كان هناك من قسمهم الى اسلام
وعلماني فالاولا المحاسبه اصبحت مطلبا حتى
تحدثنا حتى عن المحاسبه على تلك العشريه
حتى قبل قبل المجيء الرئيس قيس سعيد فالان
اذا كيف نتكلم على المحاسبه والمحاسبه
الان بدات هناك رجل اعمال حين
ربما
فقط حتى اذا سمحتي فقط متابعه لما قلت فقط
في سياق ما قلت انت تقول المحاسبه في
الواقع في البدايه صفق كثيرون لهذه الخطوه
خصوصا عندما طالت بعض السياسيين الذين
مثلا كان لهم موقف منهم ولكن الان اتسعت
الدائره والمحاسبه يبدو لم تبدا انما
الحمله الاعتقالات هي التي اتسعت
لهذا ننتظر ختم الابحاث الاوليه ودائما في
اي نصب قضائي هناك يقول وما يشمله البحث
يعني هناك ان هناك مثلا حين تحدث رئيس
الجمهوريه يتحدث قليلا حين رد على
الخالبين الخارجين الامريكيه ورد على حسب
صندوق تحدث قليلا على ما يسار وقال انها
وقال انها مؤامره كبيره واننا ونحن نسجل
رئيس الجمهوريه وننتظر من سياتيه البحث
وكما قلنا هناك
من يصدق هناك من يصدقه هناك من لا يصدق
سمير ديلو من لا يصدق ماذا امامه ان يفعل
ما هي الخطوات التي يمكن ان يلجا اليها من
يعارض
من الطريق ان ضيف ضيفكم مستعمل عباره اكثر
من سته مرات كان الاحرى ان توجه هذه
العباره الى من اعتبر هؤلاء الموقوفين
وبعضهم لم يستمع اليه بعد لا من المحقق
ولا من قاضي تحقيق اعتبارهم مجرمين
وارهابيين بل واعتبر بالامس ان كل من يبر
الى اين يريد ان يصل الرئيس هنا يعني الى
متى تستمر هذه الحمله وما الذي يمكن ان
يوقفها ويقلب الامور وهذا ما يريده
المواطن ربما الذي يسعى لتحسين ظروفه
ولكن يا سيدي لا يوجد نسخ لقرينه البراءه
كل متهم من بريء حتى تثبت ادانته ولهذا هو
الدليل على هذا ان السيد راشد الغنوشي
اليوم ذهب ذهب الى العوينه يعني ولما ولم
تصدر فيه
حين كان الصف الاول من حركه النهضه يبحثون
بحال صلاح في قضيه التصوير السيد
قمتم تترجحون علينا ان القضاء مستقل فقد
للتذكير كان هو هذه
العشريه كانت هناك ياسين متنافدين كان
هناك رجال اعمال متنفدين هناك اطراف في
الطريق يتحدث
عن ان هناك رجل اعمال
ثم اعتصم بمنزله وفارض السيد وزير العدل
نور الدين البحيري فوضع على قاضي التحقيق
وهذا من اطراف لكن اذا كانت تحكم
فكيف فكيف كانت تدار هذه الدوله هم اداروا
الدوله هم حتى من الاقتصاد وح
نحاسبهم على الاقل على حكمهم هناك من يذهب
للتحقيق ويعود وهناك من يذهب لمستشفى
الامراض العقليه واماكن اخرى سيد سمير
ديلو في النهايه
الوضع كما هو عليه يعني ما الذي يمكن ان
يكون المخرج هنا والى متى سيستمر
يبدو اني وظيفك الكريم لا نعيش في نفس
البلد ولكن الجواب عن سؤالك استاذه انا
اقول فقط ان المخرج هو في ترك القضاء يقوم
بعمله دون ضغوطات ودون تهديدات ودون ان
يخرج تخرج علينا السلطه التنفيذيه يوميا
تتحدث عن قضايا جاريه وتصدر تعليمات
للقضاه واعتبار كل من لا ينفذ تعليمات
السلطه متواطئا مع الذين يتم القاء القبض
عليهم في القانون التونسي طيله هذه
المرحله يعتبر الموقوف مشتبها به فلا يمكن
حتى ان نسميه متهم فكيف ويطلع علينا يوميا
من يسميهم مجرمين وارهابيين نحن نعيش
ظروفا غير مسبوقه في تاريخ البلاد القضاء
بصدد التعرض الى هجومات غير مسبوقه بعد
مجزره الاعفاءات وبعد الضغوطات اليوميه
ولكن المره الامر
استهداف المعارضين السياسيين الى استهداف
الاعلاميين الى التحرش بالاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الى قضايا اخيره طالت حتى
نقيب الصحفيين
والنقابيين بمناسبه ممارسه انشطه النقابيه
المعهوده تونس تحت سماء مفتوحه كل وسائل
الاعلام في العالم تتابع ما يجري في تونس
وللاسف الشديد ما يشغل العالم هو
التجاوزات الحقوقيه اليوميه للوجه المشرق
اللجنه التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاص الوطني
اشكرك واشكر محمد امين الجربي عضو تحالف
احرار من تونس
تسارعت حملات الاعتقالات في تونس وتكثفت
ويكاد يكون القاسم المشترك بينها انتقاد
الرئيس قيس سعيد وادارته لتونس ما بعد
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو تموز 2021 قائمه
الاعتقالات خلال الاسابيع الاخيره شملت
سياسيين بارزين وقاده النقابيين وناشطين
حقوقيين ابرز المعتقلين السياسيين على
العريض رئيس الحكومه الاسبق ونائب رئيس
حركه النهضه اعتقل في ديسمبر الماضي بتهمه
المسؤوليه عن تسفير الشباب التونسي الى
بؤر التوتر وبتهمه التامر على الدوله
اعتقل كذلك قياديان اخران من حركه النهضه
وهما عبد الحميد الجلاصي ونور الدين
البحيري وبالتهمه ذاتها اعتقل الوزير
السابق والقيادي في حزب نداء تونس الازهر
العكرمي وبعدها باسبوع اعتقل الامير العام
للحزب الجمهوري عصام الشابي ويواجه التهمه
نفسها وشملت الاعتقالات صحفيين ابرزهم نور
الدين بوطار المدير العام لاذاعه موزاييك
الخاصه بسبب الان من الخط التحريري
للاذاعه حسب محاميه وطالت الحمله رجل
الاعمال كمال الطيب الذي اعتقل بتهمه
التامل على امن الدوله وكان للمحامين قبل
السياسيين نصيب من الاعتقالات حيث اعتقل
سيف الدين مخلوف وهو كذلك عضو في البرلمان
المنحل بتهمه النيل من معنويات الجيش
واعتقل مهدي زقرويه ونضال السعيدي بتهمه
الاساءه الى موظف عمومي على خلفيه قضيه
المطار اما النقابيون المعتقلون فابرزهم
انيس الكعبي الكاتب العام للنقابه الطرق
السياره التابعه للاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل الذي اعتقل بتهمه تعطيل مرافق
الدوله وفي سلك القضاء اعتقل النائب العام
السابق وقد التحقيق في ملف الاغتيالات
السياسيه البشير العكرمي دون توضيح التهم
لمواجهه اليه ثم وضع في مستشفى للامراض
العقليه بعدها باسبوع
[موسيقى]
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه شل الحياه اليوم
اضراب شامل غضبا وحدادا على ارواح شهداء
مجزره نابلس ردت المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
غزه باطلاق صواريخ باتجاه عسقلان
واكدت السلطه الفلسطينيه انها ستتوجه
مجددا الى مجلس الامن الدولي بعد ان نسفت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه التفاهمات السياسيه
التي تم التوصل اليها قبل ايام بواسطه
امريكيه
غضب وحداد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه على
ارواح شهداء مجزره نابلس فالاضراب العام
شل مناحي الحياه كافه وازداد الغضب بعد
كشف مزيد من وقائع ومشاهد المجزره التي
ارتكبتها قوات الاحتلال من بينها هذه
الصور التي التقطتها كاميرات مراقبه من
احد المحال التجاريه وتظهر وحده مستعربين
تخفوا بملابس نساء ورجال بعضهم ارتدى
ملابس الصلاه والنقاب واخفوا الاسلحه
الحديثه في سجادات الصلاه اللي صار في
مدينه
احنا
منا اليوم الدراسي نعبر عن غضبنا
صار في مدينه نابلس يعني هذا اقل واجب انه
احنا نسويه يعني اللي بصير في نابلس بيصير
في القدس
جنازات الشهداء تتواصل ففي نابلس شيع
موسنا استشهد بعد اصابته في المجزره اما
في جنين فشيع الفلسطينيون مقاوما من كتيبه
جنين استشهد متاثرا باصابته بجراح قبل
اسبوعين
الجنازه تحولت الى مسيره غضب حدادا على
ارواح شهداء مجزره نابلس
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه دفعت القياده
الفلسطينيه الى العوده مجددا لمجلس الامن
الدولي معتبره ان حكومه الاحتلال نسفت
التفاهمات التي تم التوصل اليها بوساطه
امريكيه من الواضح ان اليمين الاسرائيلي
المتطرف
امثالث يواصلون تنفيذ جرائمهم بهدف تفجير
ساحه الصراع وبالتالي كان لابد لنا من
التوجه مره اخرى لمجلس الامن الدولي
ووفقا لوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فان بدايه
هذا العام هي الاكثر الدمويه في الضفه
الغربيه منذ عام 2000 اكثر من 63 شهيدا
سقطوا برصاص قوات الاحتلال في اقل من
شهرين مشهد دفع الفلسطينيين للمطالبه
مجددا بتوحيد الصف الداخلي لمواجهه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي رفعت
درجه التاهب لكنها ايضا برايهم تخطط كله
الخطوط الحمراء
الجزيره رام الله
والان ينضم الينا من رام الله مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه دكتور اهلا وسهلا بك في الحصاد
اذا يعني خلال شهرين المشهد اصبح اكثر
دمويه مما كان عليه في اكثر من 20 سنه منذ
عام 2000 تحديدا
مع كل المحاولات والوساطات الامريكيه
الاخيره كيف يفسر هذا
اخت ليلى خلال شهر واحد ارتكبت اسرائيل
ثلاث ثلاثه مجازر وحشيه
مجزره في جنين ومجزره في اريحا ومجزره
رهيبه في نابلس انا اليوم كنت في نابلس
ليس فقط لتقديم العزاء بالشهداء الذين
فقدناهم ولكن ايضا انا زرت جميع
المستشفيات ما يلفت النظر عدد الاطفال
الذين اطلق عليهم الاسرائيليون الرصاص
الحي اطفال 14 عام و13 عام و12 عام ما
ذنبهم شيوخ كبار في السن 72 عام و62 عام
الجيش الاحتلال كان يطلق الرصاص بشكل
مجنون وبدون اي انضباط وهم منسحبين قاموا
بقتل اثنين من الشهداء وهم على باب مستوصف
الرحمه يذهبون للعلاج الذي يجري انفلات
مطلق لهذه الحكومه الفاشيه العنصريه
الاكثر فاشيه وتطرفا في تاريخ المنطقه
والذي يجري هو نتيجه مباشره للصمت الدولي
على ما تقوم به اسرائيل يعني انا اليوم
تابعت ردود الافعال الدوليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي قلق والامم المتحده قلقه
والولايات المتحده قلقه ماذا يعني هذا
القلق لا يعني شيء هذا يترجم الى صفر
المطلوب ان يتم اتخاذ اجراءات عقابيه ضد
اسرائيل ان كان هناك فعلا نيه للاجم هذه
الفاشيه المنفلته من عقالها وهذا الاجرام
الوحشي الذي يهدد حياه كل فلسطيني
وفلسطينيه التفسير الوحيد لما يجري ان هذه
الحكومه الفاشيه تريد طردنا من وطننا تريد
ان تكرر نكبه عام 48 ولم ترضع الا
بمقاومتها وفرض العقوبات عليها هذه
الحكومه التي وصفتها بالوحشيه والتي
ارتكبت المجازر تفاهمت معها السلطه وهنا
السؤال
هل ما حصل اخيرا يعني فسرته ربما تفسر
اسرائيل على انه ضعف السلطه ومن ثم يعني
الضوء الاخضر مفتوح للمزيد من التعنت
خصوصا ان الامريكان لن يفعلوا شيء سوى
يتوسطون يعني
الامر يلملم
والمجزر المجزره المجزره تحصل ما هو
المخرج السلطه الفلسطينيه كيف ستتصرف الان
لماذا لا تدفعها الى موقف اكثر قوه الم
يحن الوقت لذلك دكتور مصطفى
لا لانه الولايات المتحده منحازه بشكل
مطلق لاسرائيل
وبالتالي هي مستعده ان تضغط فقط على جانب
واحد وهو الجانب الاضعف الجانب الفلسطيني
والسلطه ارتكبت خطا فادحا
بسحبها للقرار الذي كان مقدما الى مجلس
الامن
وطبعا
اسرائيليات هل هذا الخطا يصحح
اولا انا برايي يجب ان تعتذر للشعب
الفلسطيني عما جرى وثانيا نعم تستطيع ان
تصححه بان تذهب مره اخرى الى مجلس الامن
ليس فقط لطلب الحمايه ما هو طلب الحمايه
احنا نقدم وصلنا 25 سنه ولم يحدث شيء ولكن
ان تطلب ادانه الاستيطان وان تطلب ادانه
هذه المجازر وتضع الامر امام مجلس الامن
الولايات المتحده تتخذ حق النقد الفيتو
اذا ارادت ولكن ان يسمح للولايات المتحده
بالهروب من مسؤوليتها من خلال سحب القرار
هذا كان امرا خاطئا نعم يمكن تصحيحه وذلك
بالعوده مره اخرى والاصرار على نفس القرار
الذي اشكرك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك
والان الى مشهد الحرب في اوكرانيا عشيه
الذكرى الاولى لبدء الحرب
[موسيقى]
افادت مراسله الجزيره في كييفن دوي
انفجارات سمع في العاصمه الاوكرانيه نتيجه
انطلاق الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه كما
افاد المراسل الجزيره بتعرض مركز مدينه
دانياتسك في اقليم
في حين قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قواتها صدت خلال الساعات الماضيه نحو
تسعين هجوما للقوات الروسيه في اتجاهات
بخمت وكوبيانسك والايمان وشختار واشارت
الهيئه الى ان الجيش الروسي استهدف
بالصواريخ مناطق متفرقه من دونياتك
ولوغانسك
انا سعيد المتصل قلم مراسل الجزيره نقلا
عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه ان ميليشيا
فاجنر كثفت هجماتها على محاور القتال في
بخمه شمالي مقاطعه دانياسك واضافت تلك
المصادر انافاجنر احرزت تقدما عند قريه
برخيفكا شمالي المدينه لكنها تكبدت خسائر
ماديه وبشريه كبيره على حد وصف المصادر
وفي التطورات ايضا اكد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان بلاده ستواصل تعزيز
ثالوثها النووي البري والجوي والبحري وقلب
بوتين في تصريح له ان الجيش والاسطول
الحديث هما الضمان لاني وسياده البلاد
واشار الى ان العام الحالي سيشهد دخول
اولى منصات منظومه سارمت الصاروخيه للخدمه
القتاليه مؤكدا ان موسكو ستواصل الانتاج
التسلسلي لصواريخ كينجال الاسرع من الصوت
ولفت بوتين ايضا الى انها عام
2023 سيشهد تسليم كميات كبيره من صواريخ
تيركون الاسرع من الصوت والتي تطلق من
البحر
[موسيقى]
وفي تصريح عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان اي نهايه
للحرب ينبغي ان تضمن عدم قدره موسكو على
القيام بما فعلته مره اخرى اما البيت
الابيض فاعلن حزمه عقوبات سيكشف عنها غدا
كما قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس بايدن سيجري الجمعه مباحثات مع
قاده مجموعه الدول السبع والرئيس
الاوكراني
بمناسبه الذكرى السنويه للحرب
اكد الرئيس البيلاروسيه الكسندر شينكو ان
بلاده قد تشارك روسيا في معركتها مع
اوكرانيا وذلك انطلاقا من اراضي بيلاروسيا
في حال الاعتداء عليها وتواصل بيلاروسيا
تعزيز الشريط الحدودي مع اوكرانيا في وقت
تتواصل فيه الاتهامات الغربيه لبلاروسيا
بامكانيه السماح لروسيا باستخدام اراضيها
مجددا لاجتياح اوكرانيا وذلك في ضوء تشكيل
قوه عسكريه مشتركه بين موسكو ومسك
هادئه تبدو حدود بيلاروسيا مع اوكرانيا
للوهله الاولى
خلف تلك المتاريس تحشد اوكرانيا قواتها
وهنا على الضفه البيلاروسيه يواصل حرس
الحدود تدعيم الشريط الحدودي مع الجاره
اللدوده انشات هندسيه مجهزه باحدث اجهزه
المراقبه
ودوليات تكاد لا تتوقف على مدار الساعه
فالوضع رغم الهدوء الخادع يبقى متوترا
والاستفزازات من قبل اوكرانيا كما يصفها
الجانب البيلاروسي زادت وتيرتها مؤخرا
طردنا
حوادث حدوديه لان المجموعات الاوكرانيه
المسلحه اما مكونه من متطوعين او من وحدات
الدفاع الاقليميه وهي غير مختصه بحمايه
الحدود ولا يفهمون ان اي استفزاز يمكن ان
يتطور الى مواجهه حدوديه حقيقيه باستخدام
السلاح
لا تلاحظ العين حشودا عسكريه روسيه او
بيلاروسيه قرب الحدود
ربما تكون في عمق تلك الغابات
فتحركات بيلاروسيا وروسيا العسكريه اثارت
مؤخرا حواجز كثيره على الضفه الاخرى من
الحدود
العسكريه ما حليفتها موسكو
فكروا في الاعتداء على بيلاروسيا انطلاقا
من اراضي اوكرانيا او حلفائها الغربيين
وانها ليست لغز احد
تزايدت مؤخرا للاتهامات الاوكرانيه
والغربيه لمينسك بعزمها مشاركه حليفتها
موسكو في حملتها الاوكرانيه والسماح لها
باستخدام اراضي بيلاروسيا منطلقا لاجتياح
عسكري جديد لاوكرانيا كما حدث في بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه قبل عام
رئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكيشن اوضح خلال
لقائه بالصحفيين اجانب في اي حاله يمكن
لبلاده ان تكون شريكا في المعركه
الاوكرانيه
انا مستعد للقتال مع الروس من اراضي
بيلاروسيا في حاله واحده فقط ان جاء ولو
جندي واحد الى رد بيلاروسيا لقتل شعبي
لتجراتم على الاعتداء على ارضنا فسيكون
الرد مرعبا
قد تبدو مرعبه بنظر اوكرانيا وحلفائها تلك
الحشود العسكريه الروسيه البيلاروسيه
المشتركه التي انشات مؤخرا واختلفت الاراء
والتكهنات حول حقيقه دورها وامكانيه
استخدامها في المواجهه مع اوكرانيا
وحلفائها الغربيين
اجتياح القوات الروسيه لاوكرانيا من
بيلاروسيا تبدو اقل من العام الماضي نرى
كيف يريد الجانب البيلاروسي تجنب ذلك
المشكله في ان اوكرانيا والغرب حشروا منسك
في زاويه لم يتركوا لها مساحه للمناوره
يقول المثل الشعبي الاسلامي الجار لا
يختار
مثلا ينطبق على بيلاروسيا التي تحشرها
الجغرافيا بين روسيا والغرب
الجزيره بيلاروسيا
السفير الامريكي السابق لدى اوكرانيا
ونائب رئيس معهد السلام الامريكي كذلك
ينضم الينا من موسكو جيفورك مرزويان
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكما معنا
في الحصاد وابدا معك
يعني تصريح بلنكن هذا الاخير الذي يقول ان
يجب على العالم الا يضمن ان عدم قدره
موسكو عن تفعل من جديد ما فعلته في
اوكرانيا السؤال هنا هذا الكلام سمعناه في
2008 سمعناه في 2014 هل في 2023 هناك ما
يميزه هذه المراه هل يكتسب خصوصيه مختلفه
الان
نحن راينا من الان كيف ان الغرب درمته بما
في ذلك حلف الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
ومجموعه السبعه كلهم
حسدوا جهودا سويه بشكل لم يفعلوه من قبل
هذا لم يحصل في 2008 ولم يحصل في 2014 لكن
حصل في
حلف الناتو والتحالف بشكل عام دعما
لاوكرانيا
وضد العدوان الروسي ضد اوكرانيا هذا
الائتلاف لم يكن اكبر مما كان عليه الان
والعقوبات التي فرضها للتحالف اقوى من اي
شيء مماثل الدعم العسكري من حلف الناتو
لاوكرانيا للسماح باوكرانيا لان تح
روسيا لم يكن اقوى مما هو عليه الان اذا
هناك
هناك موقف مذهل وتماسك مذهل
للتحالف الغربي
الذي وصفته بالمذهل سيد ميرزيان هل يمكن
ان يضيق على بوتين ويدفعه لاستخدام سلاح
نووي صغير تكتيكي يرسل ربما رساله للعالم
هنا هل وصلنا الى هذه المرحله
استخدام السلاح النووي
للدفاع عن اراضينا وسيادينا وسيادتنا
ومواطننا سنفعل ذلك ولكن حاليا ليس هناك
اي ضروره للقيام بذلك لان روسيا تنتصر في
هذه الحرف اوكرانيا وهي تحرر الاراضي
الروسيه من النظام الاوكراني
حررت موسكو لحد الان مدينه بل كانت تسمى
سابقا
وسنتقدم ايضا في المستقبل القريب بتاع
تقرير اراضي جديده مره اخرى وهي اراضي
روسيه اما فيما يتعلق بالدعم الروسي
العفوا ان الغربي لا ارى ان امريكا او
بريطانيا او ربما الجيش الفرنسي
سيقاتلنا في اوكرانيا لانه يخافون من ذلك
سيعلمون ذلك سينتهي بحرب
نوويه حقيقيه
وبالتالي فاننا ربما وليس برقه ليس برقه
شديده من الاشراك التي تقوم وتوقفوا عن
الدخل في الشؤون الداخليه لروسيا والتوقف
عن احتلال الاراضي روسيا
والتفكير بحل لهذه المشكله اما اذا اردت
طريق الحرب فانه هتلر اراد نفس الشيء وقف
هو ايضا قال الذين تحالف كبير وقوي ضد
روسيا ولكن ننظروا محل به
يعني اذا ذهبنا الى هذا البعد سيتايلر في
النهايه اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده والغرب بشكل عام يراقب
ما يجري ولكن الان الحديث هو من جديد عن
حزمه عقوبات جديده سيعلن عنها غدا ولكن
وضع روسيا يختلف عن بقيه البلدان روسيا
لديها ما يكفي من طاقه لديها ما يكفي من
صناعات ولديها ما يكفي من مواد غذائيه وهي
مستعده لكي تتحمل حرب تستمر لسنوات هل
الغرب مستعد ايضا ليتحمل ذلك
سيكون قادرا على التحمل ذلك الغرب بهذا
التحالف الكبير من الاوروبيين والامريكيين
والشرق اسيويين العالم يدعموا اوكرانيا
دعمًا قويا الكل في العالم
يدرك ان روسيا هي التي غزت اراضي اوكرانيا
والكل في العالم يعلم ان الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
على الخط حتى لو دخلت الصين على الخط هنا
اذا ما انضمت الصين العروسيا الصين تعلم
انها ستواجه صعوبات
صينيون لم ينضموا الى روسيا لانهم يريدون
الابقاء على علاقاتهم التجاريه مع اكبر
سوقين لهم وهي وهما اوروبا وامريكا
الروس لم يدعموا الصين لم يدعموا حتى في
الامم
يعني في سياق هذه النشره ولكن اشكرك
السفير الامريكي السابق لدى اوكرانيا
ونائب رئيس معهد السلام الامريكي واشكر
كذلك ضيفنا
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي من موسكو
نتابع معكم هذه الصور من نيويورك حيث تصوت
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده على مشروع
قرار بشان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
نتابع
لفوق
من مقاعدها
الكلمه الان
لمندوبي او مندوبي
سيدي الرئيس
بالتزامنا ثابت بمثاق الامم المتحده
والقانون الدولي تدافع عن استقلاليه الدول
وسلامه اراضيها وسيادتها وحق الشعوب
بتقرير المصير ونحن نعرض
بالكامل استخدام القوه او تهديد بذلك
ونؤيد تسويه السلميه لنزاعات والخلافات
قبل عام مضى تقريبا وفي هذه الجمعيه
العامه حزرنا من ان التاريخ سوف
يطالب
الحكومه الامريكيه بتحمل المسؤوليه نتائجى
نظاما عسكريا يمتد خرج حدودها ويهدد
السلامه والامن والاستقرار على المستوى
الدولي في اوكرانيا اليوم
وبدلت من تخفيف من حدث التوترات فقد
ازدادت حدث المواجهات الميدانيه عبر
التزايد في نقل الاسلحه والخطابه العدائيه
وفرض الجزاءات احاديه الطرف مما يساهم في
تمديد الصراع لقد امتنعت عن التصويت على
مشروع القرار السبعه
وجدنا ان هذا القرار لن يساهم في تحقيق
الحوار ولن يفي غرض المفاوضات لمشاركه كل
اطراف المعنيه بهدف الوصول الى سلام
صادقا وعادل
وان هذا السلام اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من
جلسه التصويت وننوه الى ان الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده قد وافقت على مشروع قرار
يدعو الى انسحاب فوري للقوات الروسيه من
اوكرانيا
غير بعيدا عن اوكرانيا يتصاعد الخلافه
الامريكيه الصيني والموضوع اتهامات تتعلق
باحتمال امداد بيجين لموسكو بالسلاح وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان لدى واشنطن
معلومات تفيد بذلك
والامين العام لحلف النيتو
تدعم ما تحدث عنه بلينكل اما الخارجيه
الصينيه فنفت الاتهامات بينما اكدت بعثتها
لدى الامم المتحده انها ستعلن قريبا
مبادره لتسويه الازمه في اوكرانيا حديث
كان قد وصفه الرئيس الاوكراني
مشيرا الى انه من السابق لاوانه الحديث عن
خطه سلام صينيه
اكثر فاكثر تتعزز اجواء الريبه وانعدام
الثقه بين الصين والغرب على خلفيه حرب
اوكرانيا
فبيانات بيجين النافيه لتزويد روسيا
بالاسلحه تقابل بالتجاهل ولا تلقى حتى
الان اذان صاغيه لا من الولايات المتحده
ولا من حلف النيتو
وصلتنا معلومات خلال الشهور الاخيره تشير
بقوه الى ان الصين تفكر في تقديم اسلحه
الى روسيا الرئيس بايدن قال بوضوح للرئيس
الصيني خلال محادثه عبر تقنيه الفيديو ان
تقديم الصين مساعدات عسكريه الى روسيا في
الصراع باوكرانيا او اختراق العقوبات
سيمثل مشكله كبيره في العلاقات بين
الولايات المتحده والصين
بهذا التصريح يتهم بلينك الصين للمره
الثالثه خلال اسبوع
باعتزامها نقل اسلحه دون تقديم ادله غير
ان صحيفه
نقلت عن مسؤولين في اداره الرئيس بايدن ان
واشنطن تدرس اصدار معلومات استخباراتيه
بشان احتمال وجود نوايا لدى الصين لنقل
اسلحه الى روسيا وبحسب الصحيفه فان بيجين
حذره من تشجيع الروس لكنها ايضا قلقه من
تداعيات فشلهم في الحرب وعليه رجحت
التقييمات الاستخباراتيه الا تشمل
المساعدات المرتقبه اسلحه متطوره وانما
ذخائره واجزاء الكترونيه يحتاجها بعض
انواع الاسلحه وردا على ذلك عاودت
الخارجيه الصينيه نفيا ما سمتها
الافتراءات الامريكيه مؤكده دور
في البحث عن حل لانهاء الحرب
ما تسمى بالمعلومات الاستخباريه من الجانب
الامريكي ليست لا تكهنات ومحاولات لتشويه
سمعه الصين فمنذ اندلاع الازمه في
اوكرانيا وقفت الصين بحزم الى جانب الحوار
والسلام ولعبت دورا مسؤولا وبناء في تخفيف
الوضع وحل الازمه من خلال تعزيز محادثات
السلام بطريقه الخاصه
الاتهامات الغربيه للصين بدعم موسكو في
حربها على اوكرانيا بدات الجمعه الماضيه
على هامش ملتقى ميونخ للامن لكنها تصاعدت
بعد استقبال الرئيس الروسي لوزير الخارجيه
الصيني في موسكو
وموجها رساله الى واشنطن كشف بوتين عن
زياره مرتقبه لنظيره الصيني واشاد
بالمستوى الرفيع الذي بلغته علاقات
البلدين لا سيما على الصعيد التجاري مركز
الدراسات الدفاعيه المتطوره في الولايات
المتحده توقع ان ترسل الصين الى روسيا
اجزاء الكترونيه لرادارات الصواريخ
المضاده للطائرات وذكر المركز ان بعض
الشركات الصينيه توفر المسيرات المدنيه
مستغله المساحه الرماديه بين الاغراض
العسكريه والمدنيه تقارير لا ترقى بعد الى
حد اليقين لكنها كفيله بتاجيج رجال الغربي
الصيني ودفع الازمه بين الطرفين الى
مستويات متقدمه من التصعيد
مساحات التصعيد الامريكيه الصيني اوسع مما
جاء بخصوص دعم روسيا بالسلاح لعل اهمها
تايوان اذ نقلت صحيفه
عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان واشنطن تخطط لنشر
ما بين 100 جندي ومئتي جندي في تايوان
خلال الاشهر المقبله وبحسب مصادر الصحيفه
فانها القوه الامريكيه ستوسع برنامجا
تدريبيا لتزويد تايوان بقدرات دفاعيه كما
اوردت الوصف
الوطنيه الامريكي يقوم بتدريب فرقه من
الجيش التايواني في ميشيغان
وتاريخ الاتفاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
بشانها منذ اعلان شنهايه ستكون موضوعنا
بعد قليل في فقره في المتابعه
[موسيقى]
جددت محكمه مصريه حبس الصحفيين في الجزيره
مباشر هشام عبد العزيز وبهاء ابراهيم
ليتجاوز حبسهما ثلاث سنوات دون محاكمه
وكانت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه اصدرت بيانا
دعت فيه للافراج الفوري عن الصحفي بهاء
الدين ابراهيم وزميليه المعتقلين في مصر
وقالت في بيانها ان الزميل بهاء الدين
ابراهيم المنتج في قناه الجزيره مباشر
اكمل ثلاث سنوات في السجون المصريه واشارت
الى تعرض الزميل بهاء الدين لانتهاكات
قانونيه مستمره منها الاخفاء القصري
والتعذيب بالكهرباء والحبس الانفرادي
وقد اعربت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه عن
قلقها الشديد على سلامه الزميل بهاء الدين
ابراهيم وزميليه هشام عبد العزيز وربيع
الشيخ المحتجزين كذلك دون محاكمه في
زنازين تفتقر لابسط شروط الصحه والنظافه
ودعت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه في بيانها كل
الهيئات المعنيه بحريه الصحافه والمنظمات
الحقوقيه في العالم دعتهم جميعا الى
الوقوف مع الزميل بهاء الدين ابراهيم
وغيره من الصحفيين المسجونين في مصر
والمطالبه باطلاق سراحهم فورا
ومعنا الان من فيينا
وهو المدير التنفيذي للمعهد الدولي
للصحافه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد مربج في الحصاد
كيف تلقيتم خبر تمديد اعتقال صحفيه
الجزيره
اعتقد انه امر مشين تماما ان يتم
احتجاز وتوقيف وحبس صحفيين لاكثر من ثلاث
سنوات ومن دون ان تتم محاكمته هم فقط يتم
توقيفهم بشكل مستمر والتوقيف في مثل هذه
الظروف يعني حرمانهم من العداله لان تاخير
العداله يعني الحرمان منها ونفهم ايضا ان
هؤلاء الصحفيين يعانون من العزله ومن
التعذيب هذا امر سيء للغايه والمعهد
الدولي للصحافه الذي يمثل صحفيين محررين
يطالب السلطات المصريه باستمرار باطلاق
سراحهم وهذا الامر استمر على مدى ثلاث
سنوات هل هناك خطه مثلا معينه تنوون
تقديمها
موقف جديد من جانبكم
اعتقد ان هناك حاجه لان تكون هناك حملات
مستمره وثابته وهذا ما تقوم به منظمتنا
ومنظمات الاخرى نفهم ان السلطات المصريه
اطلقت سراح احد زملائكم في وقت سابق من
العام الماضي اذا هناك شيء من التقدم مما
يدل على ان الضغط والحملات تؤتي وكلها
لكنها يجب ان تستمر ولا تستمر على مستوى
منظمات المجتمع المدني فقط كما نحن لكن
يجب ان يتم على مستوى سياسي على مستوى
الدول والحكومات لتطالبه بذلك لان
الصحفيين في كل مكان بالعالم يجب ان يحظى
بحريتهم ليمارسوا عملهم المدير التنفيذي
للمعهد الدولي للصحافه من فيينا شكرا
جزيلا على وجودتنا
اتهم مركز الشهاب لحقوق الانسان السلطات
المصريه بارتكاب انتهاكات موسعه ضد
المعتقلين في داخل سجن بدر ثلاثه وقال
المركز الحقوقي ان السلطات المصريه تتعنت
منذ سبعه اعوام في منع الاهالي من زياره
ذويهم المعتقلين محذرا من ان عددا من
المعتقلين اقدم على الانتحار نتيجه
المعاملات السيئه واضاف المركز الحقوقي ان
معتقلين داخل السجن بداوا اضرابا احتجاجا
على ظروف اعتقالهم السيئه الامر الذي
واجهته اداره السجن بمزيد من التعسف
والعنف واكد المركز الحقوقي ان المرشد
العام لجماعه الاخوان دخل في اضراب كلي
بسبب المعامله السيئه من قبل اداره السجن
له وعدم الاستجابه له في الذهاب للمستشفى
ومنعه من حضور الجلسات امام النيابه وكان
تقرير لوكاله رويترز سلطت الضوء على ما
وصفها بانتهاكات حقوق الانسان في سجن بدر
ثلاثه واشار الى انه يتم حرمان النزلاء من
الرعايه الصحيه ويتم اخضاعهم لمعامله
عقابيه تشمل العزل
الى تركيا الان حيث ضربت هزه ارضيه بقوه
خمس درجات على مقياس ريختر ولايه هاتاي
جنوبيه البلاد عفوا ياتي هذا في وقت اعلنت
فيه سلطات تركيا انها ستهدم مدينه نورداك
بشكل كامل وذلك بسبب تضرر مبانيها
كان رمضان في الخامسه من عمره عندما ضرب
زلزال هذه المنطقه فدمر كل ممتلكات عائلته
بعد خمسين عاما تماما دمر الزلزال الاخير
محطه الوقود هذه ومحال تجاريه اخرى يملكها
لدي بيت في نورداغ ولدي محلان تجاريان
اخران كل ذلك دمر لا اعرف ماذا افعل هل
سيسمح لنا بالبناء في المنطقه مجددا هل
سيبنون ويعطوننا منزلا لا اعرف
يقول رمضان ان كل ما خسره لا قيمه له امام
نجاه عائلته وهو يدرك ان طريق تلافي
الخسائر الماديه سيكون صعبا
بعد كارثه تقول لي شركه التامين لو حصل
انفجار كنا عوضناك لماذا اذا كنت اؤمن على
محطه ضد الكوارث منذ سنوات
فالصور داخل مدينه نوردا تكشف عن خسائر
ماديه كبيره لاصحاب المحال التجاريه اتخذ
قرار بهدم المدينه باكملها قريبا لقد ضاع
كل شيء هنا
يجد خليل صعوبه في تقدير خسائر متجره ولا
يعرف ايضا ان كان سيقف على قدميه مجددا
نستطيع فعله هو انقاذ ما تبقى من بضاعه
ووضعها في مكان ما والانتظار لا اعرف ان
كنت ساستطيع فتح دكان مره اخرى عن مدينه
مدمره بالكامل
تشير الاحصاءات الرسميه الى انهيار اكثر
من 300 واربعين مبنا في المدينه بما تحويه
من منازل ومكاتب ودكاكين ومحل صناعيه
وتجاريه حتى سوقوا بيع السيارات الزراعيه
والصناعيه الذي كانت المدينه تعتمد عليه
اصيب باضرار جسيمه لا
تقتصر المحل التجاريه تعاني المصير نفسها
وهو ما سيزيد من صعوبه الاوضاع المعيشيه
في مقبل الايام مع خساره الاله لموارد
رزقهم
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره
[موسيقى]
حيث نحاول استدعاء الخلفيه التاريخيه
للنزاع المستمر منذ اكثر من سبعه عقود
تايوان هي الخبيل من الجزر جنوب شرقي اسيا
يفصلها مضيق عن البر الصينيه على بعد نحو
140 كيلومترا بدات القصه عام
1949 عندما فرت اليها الحكومه الوطنيه اثر
انتصار الشيوعيين في الحرب الاهليه
وسيطرتهم على بر الصين الرئيسي
القرن الماضي كانت الصين كدوله اي انها
تجلس في المقعد الدائم في مجلس الامن
وفيها السفارات الخاصه بالدول الاخرى هذا
الوضع انتهى مع بدايه السبعينيات القرن
الماضي عندما قرر الرئيس الامريكي ريتشارد
زياره الصين لاسبوع هذا الاسبوع عرف لاحقا
بالاسبوع الذي غير العالم في النهايه ادت
الاتصالات وزيارات الى التطبيع العلاقات
لكن ليس في عهد نيكسون انما في عهد الرئيس
جيمي
طبعا تطور العلاقات
اسس على تفهمات بين الطرفين اهمها سياسه
الصين الواحده اي اعتراف امريكي صريح
بوحده الصين
ومنح بيجين المقعد الدائم في مجلس الامن
في الامم المتحده وذلك مقابل الالتزام
بالجن بعدم اجتياح تايوان عسكريا
واشنطن اكدت على حمايه تايوان ووضعها تحت
مظلتها النوويه هذا ما سنناقشه مع ضيفنا
من جناز
لينال تاتون الاستاذ المساعد للعلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه ويبسر والباحث في معهد
تاريخ الاسلحه العالمي في جامعه ميجي
اليابانيه
اذا هناك تغير اولا طبعا اهلا بك في
الحصاد
شيء ما يحصل الان هذا التسريب عن وصف
الجنر عن تدريب عسكريين ايضا الزيارات
الاخيره
كيف يمكن توصيف ما يجري حاليا
ما اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده تستمر في
القيام به بما تقوم به منذ سنوات وهو
محاوله اعداد التايوان لاحتمال الدخول في
نزاع او حرب عبره مضيقه تايوان وهنا انشاء
النواش نشرت انه هناك زياده في الوجود
العسكري الامريكي في تايوان وتدريب
وتدريب الجيش التايواني لمواجهه اي غزو
صيني لكن الصين اصبحت اكثر قوه من الماضي
وبالتالي في توازن القوى بين تايوان الصين
اصبح محتلا وبالتالي على الولايات المتحده
ان تعوض ذلك لصالح التايوان وان هذه
السياسه الامريكيه منذ
اذا سمحت هل هل الدعم الغربي الكبير
لاوكرانيا
ربما يلعب دور ويجعل الصين تفكر مرتين قبل
ان تقدم على اي تحرك فيما يتعلق بتايوان
لا اعتقد ان هناك اي علاقه مباشره بين
الوضع في اوكرانيا والوضع في عبره تايوان
طبعا الصين
لديها علاقه اوثق مع روسيا هذا امر واضح
واعتقد الان ان الصين ايضا تريد ان تدعم
موسكو وقد شاهدنا ان هناك زياره لمسؤول
كبير الصيني الى موسكو لكن الامر ما زال
مقصور على الجانب الدبلوماسي اما في ما
يتعلق بالدعم العسكري فان الصيد فرقت تركز
على منطقتها في اسيا واعتقد ان الصيام ان
الصين لحد الان ليس لديها ربط لا تربط بين
مسرحيه من ناحيه العسكريه اطلاقا من الفتى
الاستاذ مسعد للعلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
ويسترن والبحث في تاريخ الاسلحه شكرا
جزيلا لك
اذا راس الساعه واليكم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين
اتساع لحمله الاعتقالات في تونس تهمون
بالارهاب ضد الامين العام للحزب الجمهوري
وعضوا في جبهه الخلاص رئيس جبهه الخلاص
يقولون للجزيره ان الاعتقالات تعم كل
الاوساط النهضه تدعو للكف عن ملاحقه رموز
المعارضه وعلى راسهم الغنوشي والرئيس
السعيد يقول انه يعمل على انقاذ الدوله
ولم يتراجع عن ذلك
في تداعيات عمليه اسرائيل في نابلس وقتلها
11 فلسطينيين اضراب مفتوح في القدس والضفه
والقطاع تمديدا بما وصفت بالمجزره البيت
الابيض يقول انه ياسف لسقوط ضحايا مدنيين
ويعلن وصول كبير مستشاري بايدن للشرق
الاوسط الى المنطقه منسق الامم المتحده
لعمليه سلام يبحث في غزه جهود خفض التوتر
على الحرب الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
توافق على مشروع قرار يدعو الى انسحاب
فوري للقوات الروسيه من اوكرانيا بوتين
يلوح بالترسانه النوويه تزامنا واعلانها
العزم على نشر صواريخ سارمات عابره
القارات
يتعهد بتحقيق النصر
على واقع اتهامات من الولايات المتحده
وحلف النيتو بنيتها دعم روسيا باسلحه
فتاكه الصين تقول انها ستعلن قريبا مبادره
لتسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا
وتنفي الاتهامات الغربيه والرئيس
الاوكراني يرحب بانخراطها في محادثات
السلام
وتتابعون ايضا
تمديد اعتقال صحفي شبكه الجزيره دون
محاكمه في مصر وتنديد حقوقي الدولي بتجديد
حبسهم دون سند قانوني
اذا تستمر في تونس حمله الاعتقالات
والايقافات التي بداتها السلطات هذا الشهر
والتي استهدفت عددا من السياسيين
والاعلاميين والمحامين بينهم رئيس الحزب
الجمهوري عصام الشابي والقياديه في شبه
الخلاص المعارضه شيماء عيسى وقال الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد انه لا بد من القضاء على
من وصفها بالخلايا السرطانيه داخل الدوله
اما بالاشعه او بالعلاج الكيميائي على حد
تعبيره
حمله الاعتقالات الامنيه والملاحقات
القضائيه استهدفت رئيس الحزب الجمهوريه
عصام الشابي والقياديه البارزه في جبهه
الخلاص الوطني شيماء عيسى لتتسع القائمه
التي ضمت سياسيين وحقوقيين ومحامينا
ونقابيين ملاحقات اعتبرتها المعارضه تصفيه
حساب من الرئيس قيس سعيد مع خصومه
السياسيين ومنتقديه من جميع الاطياف
المدنيه والنقابيه
كل هذه الحمله تستهدف قوى الديمقراطيه
القوه المناهضه للانقلاب القوى اللي قالت
لقيس سعيد لا للحكم الفردي لا للاستبداد
ولا للعوده لما قبل الثوره لكن الرئيس قيس
سعيد يؤكد ان الايقافات تاتي على خلفيه
تامر المعتقلين على امن الدوله الداخلي
والخارجي وانها تتم دون انتهاك للحقوق
والحريات
مع الحرصي على استقلاليه القضاء هي حرب
تحرير وطني ولابد من تحرير الوطن من كل
هؤلاء الادرار
الشعب التونسي الى الوراء ونحن نحن
الامانه في حين هم ياخذون في الواقع كامل
الفكر الاجرامي لتحطيم الدوله ولضرب الوطن
وفي ظل ما تشهده البلاد تثار اسئله حول
حظوظ نجاح اي مبادره لحوار وطني ينزع فتيل
الازمه او يخفف حاله الاحتقان لا يوجد
حوار الحوار المطلوب هو حوار يجمع المجتمع
التونسي مع بعضه البعض بكل مكونات وقوات
سياسيه والحيه والمجتمعيه حول اي تونس
نريد هل هي تونس العنصريه القمعيه التي
تعود بنا الى قرون ماضيه حيث يحكم الملك
ونحن نطيع هي تونس تنهض من رمادها وتؤسس
لدوله دوله القانون والحريات ح تحرير
الوطني كما يصفها سعيد جبهت بانتقادات
داخليه وخارجيه والخيط الناظم بين هذه
التفاعلات التعبير عن القلق والانشغال
والدعوه الى الحوار سدب عليك الجزيره تونس
هذا واكد رئيس الجبهه الخلاص الوطني في
تونس احمد نجيب الشابي ان رئيس الحزب
الجمهوريه عصام الشابي لم يتامر على
البلاد وقال الشاب في تصريحنا الجزيره ان
عصام الشاب بامكانه ان يتحمل الكثير ولن
يجدوا ما يواجهون به الراي العام الوطني
الاتهامه واضاف ان حمله الاعتقالات تتوسع
وتعم كل الاوساط ولم تعد تقتصر على
السياسيين وان هناك حاله من التخبط والعبث
وفق تعبيره
هناك حاله من التخبط واحاذا من العبث هي
سببها
الخيمه التي عاشها السيد قيس سعيد اثناء
الانتخابات التشريعيه في دورتها الاولى
ودورتها الثانيه حيث سحب سحب
المواطن ثقته بالكامل من مساره السياسي ثم
فشله الثريه في اداره الشان الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي تونس على ابواب الانهيار
والافلاس وكذلك عجز مطبق في اداره
العلاقات الخارجيه لتونس كل هذه النتائج
تجعله يهرب الى الامام في محاوله لاسكات
الاصوات الحره
هذا وقرر قاضي تحقيق بسكنه الحرس الوطني
الابقاء على رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي في حاله سراح وقد مثل الغنوشي
امام محققا امني في فكره الحرس الوطني في
العوينه في العاصمه التونسيه للاستماع
اليه في قضيه جديده رفعها ضده احد
الامنيين وكانت حركه النهضه قالت في وقت
سابق ان الملاحقات التي تتم في حق رئيسها
تندرج في اطار التصفيه السياسيه لمعارضي
الانقلاب
هذا وكانت حركه النهضه دعت الى الكف عن
ملاحقه رموز المعارضه في تونس وعلى راسهم
راشد الغنوشي تحت غطاء التهم المزيفه
والملفقه بحسب تعبيرها كما دعت الحركه
القضاه الشرفاء الى عدم الانصياع لضغوط
السلطه وعدم الخوف من تحريضها ضدهم وتعريض
حياتهم وحياه عائلاتهم للخطر كما دعت الى
اطلاق سراح كل من وصفتهم بالموقوفين ظلما
من سياسيين ونقابيين واعلاميين ورجال
اعمال وغيرهم
ومن تونس معنا الان احمد الهمامي المتحدث
باسم تحالف احرار وكذلك احمد النفاتي
النائب رئيس حزب العمل والانجاز والعضو في
جبهه الخلاص الوطني اهلا بكما وابدا معك
احمد الهمامي يعني من يتابع المشهد
حاله
وصفها ربما نشيد نجيب الشابي بانها حاله
من الفوضى ولكن اذا استبعدنا ما يقوله شخص
يعترض على مواقف الرئيس بشكل عام ما يجري
يدل على شيء من الفوضى لماذا
شكرا لك اهلا وسهلا هذا الحذف التعبيرات
المعارضين التعبيرات الاشخاص خلينا نكونوا
واضحين يعني عندما الشعب التونسي رفع شعار
المحاسبه في العشريه السوداء المحاسبه
بالمن خلينا نحط النقاط عن الحروف الذي
كان يحكم في تونس الى 10 سنوات هم الذي
سيسالون
امام القضاء لا نستطيع ان نذهب الى شخصا
مارن في الطريق العام وناتي له ونقول له
انت متهم في البلاد لمده 10 سنوات اذا
الذين سيسالون امام القضاء القانون هم من
حكموا لمده عشريه سوداء من رؤساء حكومات
من وزراء من نواب
من الذين كانوا مسؤولين على التشريعات
القانونيه وهو مختلف
ذلكم باكيا وتظالما يعني كل مره هذه
اعتقالات سياسيه هذه اعتقالات سياسيه نعم
نعم نحن نتوجه بالمحاسبه لمن حكم في
العشريه السوداء وهم يعني بهذا المنطق
يعني كيف تفسر اذن اعتقال اعلاميين اعتقال
نشطاء ليس فقط سياسيين
الموجه تطالب الجميع على ما يبدو اي شخص
يجرى ان يعبر عن رايه المعارض
شكرا لك مره اخرى ولكن هذا سؤالك غريب
حقيقه الامر لانه السياسيين الذي افسدوا
في البلاد
هناك اعلانيون رجال اعمال الموالة حملات
الانتخابيه هناك من مولى اذاعات هناك من
الاعلاميين منطقه وتحدث عن سعيد وهو يعني
هناك اخطبوط كامل في السن الهلال لمده
عشره سنوات اذا كونوا واقعين من هو بريء
ما هو سيخرج من ايقافه
ما المشكله لماذا هذه المبالغه والتضخيم
هو مجرد تحقيق واشخاص يتم التحقيق معهم
والبريء سيخرج
السلام عليكم جميعا هذه الاعتقال وقعت في
سياق سياسي مشبوه يعني منذ مسار 25 جويليه
منذ سنتين ونصف والسلطه القائمه اختارت ان
يحكم الرئيس بمفرده ويلغي كل المؤسسات
الشرعيه منها البرلمان وكل المؤسسات
المنتخبه الاخرى يعني بعد فشل في حل
المشاكل الحقيقيه وهي المشاكل الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه يعني هذه الاعتقالات في في كل
هذا السياق يعني المشبوهه وصفت بالتصفيه
السياسيه يعني الرئيس منذ سنتين ونصف وهو
يعني
يتهم المحتكرين ويقول ان الازمه
الاقتصاديه يعني وراءها المحتكرون وراءها
الفاسدين وثم لا نجد المحتكرين في السجون
ولا الفاسدين في السجون بل نجد المعارضه
السياسيه ورموز المعارضه السياسيه في
السجون بتهم تامر على امن الدوله بتهم تصل
هذه التهم الى الارهاب يعني كل هذا السياق
الوطني هذا سياق مخيف والحريات في مهدده
يعني
الفتره الاخيره كان النظام في راحه خاصه
وان عندما كانت المعارضه مشته ولكن يوم 14
في ذكرى احياء الثوره تم توحيد موقف
الانقلاب وهناك العديد من الاحزاب التي
يعني التي كانت مع مسار 25 جويليه قامت
بمراجعات ونزلت يوم 14 جانفي الى شارع
الثوره والتحقت بالمعارضه ضد هذا المسار
وضد مسار 25 جويليه هذا توحد في الموقف
يعني زعزعه كيان السلطه القائمه
ومما جعل هذا يعني
وبعد التوحد في هذا الموقف هناك
وجود ملاحظه يعني وانقل الفكره هذه لاحمد
الهمامي بالفعل في البدايه كانت هناك كثير
من المهللين
لاجراءات التي اتخذها قيس سعيد سواء
بالنسبه لاعتقال بعض الرموز او بالنسبه
لبعض القوانين التي سنه ما الى اليوم
المشهد مختلف هناك عدد كبير من الشباب ومن
يعني قطاعات مختلفه لهم راي اخر بداوا
يشعرون بان الامر قد زاد عن حده
شكرا
هم ابناء الشعب العادي وليست هذه الاحزاب
السياسيه لان هذه الاحزاب السياسيه كانت
متمعشه من العشريه السوداء دعونا نتحدث مع
الشعب بصراحه تامه يعني يوم الذي تحدث
عليه بضيفكم لم يستطيعوا تجميع الناس
حولهم وهذا بالاثباتات وبعددهم وبصور
وبالفيديوهات لم يستطيعوا تجميع الشعب
الشعب كره هؤلاء وكلما لاحظنا ان الرئيس
قيس سعيد توجه الى الشارع وتوجه الى
المواطن لا نسمع سوى كلمه المحاسبه سيد
الرئيس الشعب معك سيد الرئيس نريد
المحاسبه يعني دعونا من ترهات هذه هي
اقابات سياسيه الاولى
اشكرك احمد الهمامي للاسف هذا ما يسمح به
الوقت المتحدث باسم التحالف احرار واشكر
ايضا احمد النفاتي نائب رئيس حزب العمل
والانجاز والعضو في هيئه او في جبهه
الخلاص الوطني شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
الان الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه التي شلل
الحياه اليوم فيها اضراب شامل غضبا وحدادا
على ارواح شهداء مجزره نابلس وقد ردت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه باطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه عسقلان وسديروت واكدت
السلطه الفلسطينيه انها ستتوجه مجددا الى
مجلس الامن الدولي بعد ان نسفت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التفاهمات السياسيه التي تم
التوصل اليها قبل ايام بوساطه امريكيه
غضب وحداد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه على
ارواح شهداء مجزره نابلس فالاضراب العام
شل مناحي الحياه كافه وازداد الغضب بعد
كشف مزيد من وقائع ومشاهد المجزره التي
ارتكبتها قوات الاحتلال من بينها هذه
الصور التي التقطتها كاميرات مراقبه من
احد المحالي التجاريه وتظهر وحده مستعربين
تخفوا بملابس نساء ورجال بعضهم ارتدى
ملابس الصلاه والنقاب واخفوا الاسلحه
الحديثه في سجادات الصلاه اللي صار في
مدينه
احنا من اليوم اضراف لنعبد عن غضبنا
صار في مدينه نابلس يعني هذا اقل واجب انه
احنا نسويه يعني اللي بيصير في نابلس
بيصير في القدس
جنازات الشهداء تتواصل ففي نابلس شيع
موسنا استشهد بعد اصابته في المجزره اما
في جنين فشيع الفلسطينيون مقاوما من كتيبه
جنين استشهد متاثرا باصابته بجراح قبل
اسبوعين
الجنازه تحولت الى مسيره غضب حدادا على
ارواح شهداء مجزره نابلس
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه دفعت القياده
الفلسطينيه الى العوده مجددا لمجلس الامن
الدولي معتبره ان حكومه الاحتلال نصفت
التفاهمات التي تم التوصل اليها بوساطه
امريكيه من الواضح ان اليمين الاسرائيلي
المتطرف امثال بن جافير وسميطريتش يواصلون
تنفيذ جرائمهم بهدف تفجير ساحه الصراع
وبالتالي كان لابد لنا من التوجه مره اخرى
لمجلس الامن الدولي
ووفقا لوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فان بدايه
هذا العام هي الاكثر الدمويه في الضفه
الغربيه منذ عام 2000 اكثر من 63 شهيدا
سقطوا برصاص قوات الاحتلال في اقل من
شهرين مشهد دفع الفلسطينيين للمطالبه
مجددا بتوحيد الصف الداخلي لمواجهه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي رفعت
درجه التاهب لكنها ايضا برايهم تخطط كله
الخطوط الحمراء
الجزيره رام الله هذا وقالت مجموعه عرينا
الاسود انها منذ المجزره في مدينه نابلس
واستشهاد سته مقاومين انضم نحو 50 مقاتلا
جديدا لصفوفها واضافت مجموعات تعارن
الاسود في بيان ان من يراهن على انهائها
واهم وضعيف ودعت الفلسطينيين في كل مدينه
وقريه ومخيم للانخراط فورا في العمل مقاوم
مهما كانت الادوات ولكن بتخطيط جيد حسب
تعبيرها واكدت ان ضربات التي تلقتها لا
تزيد عناصرها الا اصرارا على مواصله
الطريق والاشتباك مع الاحتلال
قالت المتحدثات باسم البيت الابيض كان ان
الاداره الامريكيه تتابع عن كثب المداهمه
الاسرائيليه الاخيره في نابلس وانها تاسف
لسقوط ضحايا مدنيين واضافت المتحدثه نواش
تدرك بواحث قلق اسرائيل لكنها قلقه للغايه
من استمرار العنف واشارت الى ان منسق
البيت الابيض لشؤون الشرق الاوسط يقود
وفدا امريكيا يزور المنطقه وانا زياره
تشمل مصر والاردن وعمان والامارات
التقى مبعوث الامم المتحده لعمليه السلام
في الشرق الاوسط
قياده حركه حماس في غزه وقالت مصادر
فلسطينيه ان المبعوثه الامريكي او
المبعوثه الامامي بالاحرى بحث ملفات عده
ابرزها خفض حاله التوتر وعدم التصعيد في
اطار الجهود التي تبذلها الامم المتحده في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
قبل عام بالضبط في مثل هذه الساعات كانت
القوات الروسيه تجتاز حدودها نحو اوكرانيا
لتبدا حربا غيرت الكثير في المشهد العالمي
[موسيقى]
بعد عام اذا ما زال الرئيس الاوكراني
بلودوميرسكي يتعهد بتحقيق النصر على ما
سماها القوات الغازيه اما الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين فقد بلغ مستوى التصعيد من
جهته ان اكد مواصله بلاده تعزيز قواتها
النوويه برا وبحرا وجوا وقال بوتين ان
العام الحالي سيشهد دخول اولى منصات
منظومات صارمه الصاروخيه للخدمه القتاليه
وقبل اقل من ساعه من الان تبنت الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده باغلبيه مئه وواحد
واربعين صوتا قرارا يجدد مطالبه روسيا بان
تسحب فورا وبشكل كامل ودون اي شرط جميع
قواتها العسكريه من اراضي اوكرانيا
ويدعو الى وقف الاعمال العدائيه القرار
المقدم من اوكرانيا يشدد على ضروره التوصل
في اقرب وقت ممكن الى سلام شامل وعادل
ودائم في اوكرانيا بما يتفق ومبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده كما اعاد القرار التاكيد
على التزام الجمعيه العامه بسياده
اوكرانيا واستقلالها ووحدتها وسلامتها
الاقليميه داخل حدودها المعترف بها دوليا
يشدد القرار الامامي ايضا على ضروره ضمان
المساءله عن الجرائم الاشد خطوره وفق
تصنيف القانون الدولي
مرتكبه على اراضي اوكرانيا وذلك من خلال
تحقيقات ومحاكمات تكون مناسبه وعادله
ومستقله
ومن مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك ينضم
الينا الان مراسلنا مراد هاشم مراد حدثنا
عن ما جرى في جلسه التصويت وما الذي يعني
التوصل الى هذا القرار
نعم الليله اغلبيه ساحقه اغلبيه الثلثين
صوتت لصالح هذا القرار الذي قدمته
اوكرانيا
ورعته اكثر من سبعين دوله وصوتت لصالحه
141 دوله اظهر بالفعل كما ارادت الدول
الغربيه روسيا معزوله داخل الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده الا من دعم ست دول
رفضت هذا القرار الى جانب روسيا وهي
بيلاروسيا
المالي نيكاراغوا سوريا كوريا الشماليه
ارتيريا
لكن هناك دول مهمه ايضا تحفظت على هذا
القرار وعلى راسها الصين والهند
وجنوب افريقيا وايران وباكستان والجزائر
وعدد كبير من الدول الافريقيه
بطبيعه الحال هذا القرار ما يميزه عن جمله
القرارات التي اعتمدتها الجميع العامه منذ
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا انه اكثر قرارات
التي تضمنت
مواد تتعلق بالسلام وتدعو للسلام وتدعم
الحل السلمي وذلك في محاوله لجلب اكبر عدد
من الاصوات وهو ما تحقق اذ كان الهاجس
هاجس الداعمين لهذا القرار ان يكون هناك
عدد اقل من الاصوات مقارنه بما حصلت عليه
القرارات السابقه وبالتالي ما يرسل رسائل
تشجيع لروسيا وهو ما لم يحدث روسيا مع ذلك
رات ان هذه المضامين تعكس بطبيعه الحال
خوف الدول الغربيه من انها بالفعل بدات
تفقد بعض التاييد العالمي وهي دعمت
التعديلات التي انت قدمت بها بيلاروسيا
والتي كانت تحذف الدعوه الى سحب روسيا
لقواتها وكذلك انهاء الحرب
وتدعو الى مفاوضات لحل السلمي وكذلك الى
وقفه ارسال الاسلحه الى من قبل الاطراف
الثالثه الى مناطق القتال وهي تعديلات لم
تحصل على التاييد الكافي داخل القاعه
بطبيعه الحال هذه الجلسه هي الجلسه
الاستثنائيه الطارئه الحادي عشر واستانفت
في ذكرى مرور عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
ليلا وبلا شك سنتابع تداعيات نتائج هذا
التصويت اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات مراد
هاشم من نيويورك
وفي تصريح عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان اي نهايه
للحرب ينبغي ان تضمن عدم قدره موسكو على
القيام بما فعلته مره اخرى اما البيت
الابيض فاعلن عن حزمه عقوبات سيكشف عنها
غدا كما قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
ان الرئيس بايدن سيجري الجمعه مباحثات مع
قاده مجموعه الدول السبع والرئيس
الاوكراني
بمناسبه الذكرى السنويه للحرب
طبعا هذا المشهد برمته من تطورات ميدانيه
وتصعيد في مجالات ومستوى التهديد شكل مع
الحرب نقطه تحول محوريه في استراتيجيات
حلف شمال الاطلسي النيتو وفرضت عليه
رهانات وتحديات جديده فقد سرع وتيره
التوسعه شرق اوروبا من خلال نشر مزيد من
القوات قرب الحدود مع روسيا وعلى خط موازن
باشر اجراءات ضم دول جديده لعضويته في
محاوله لاحتواء التهديدات الروسيه
المحتمله
صيف 2022 بمقر النيتو في بروكسل فنلندا
والسويد تتقدمان بطلب العضويه في حلف شمال
الاطلسي كان الاعتقاد حينها ان عمليه
الانضمام للحلف ستمضي دون عقبات
البلدين اللذان ظل على الحياد منذ انشاء
الحلف قبل سبعه عقود قرر في حمئه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وما تلاها من
تداعيات تغيير موقفهما فنلندا الجاره
المباشره لروسيا رات في الامر ضروره ملحه
نقدر كثيرا دعم الحلف لعضويه فنلندا
ونتطلع الى عمليه التصديق السريعه لن
تساهم عضويه كل من فنلندا والسويد في
تعزيز امننا فحسب بل الامن الجماعي للحلف
ان مفهوم الاستراتيجيه الذي تم قبوله في
مدريد سيزيد الامن والاستقرار في اوروبا
لكن بعد عشره اشهر يظل قرار ضم البلدين
للحلف
رهنا بموقف انقره المطالبه بشروط ترى
هيلسنكي وستوكهولم انه تم استيفائها قناعه
يتقاسمها امين عام الحلف الذي حث على
تسريع اليات الضم قبل قمه الحلف المقرره
صيف العام الجاري
لقد حان الوقت للموافقه على انضمام فنلندا
والسويد للحلف لقد قطعت خطوات كبيره منذ
توقيعنا على التصريح المشترك معهما ومع
تركيا في قمه
الماضي لقد رفعت الدولتان القيود عن صادره
الاسلحه وعززه تشريعاتهما بشان الارهاب
كما تقوم السويد بتعديل دستورها وبدات
تنفيذ اليه لمواصله العمل ايضا مع تركيا
في مكافحه الارهاب على وقع الحرب عزز
الحلف جبهته الشرقيه من خلال انشاء
مجموعات قتاليه في بلغاريا واستونيا
والمجر واللادفيا وليتوانيا وبولندا
ورومانيا وسلوفاكيا كما ارسل مزيدا من
السفن والطائرات والقوات الى الجناح
الشرقي للنيتو من بحر البلطيق في الشمال
الى البحر الاسود في الجنوب
وبينما يتمدد الحلف شرقا تتطلع دول
البلقان وجورجيا ومللدوفا الى دعم النيتو
في مواجهه الضغوط الروسيه فيما يبدو سعيا
لتلافي تكرار سيناريو اوكرانيا هي اعاده
رسم لحدود ظل الحلف يحافظ عليها منذ نهايه
الحرب البارده لكنه بدا يتخطاها كما تقول
روسيا على نحو متسارع يمر الانضمام الى
النيتو بمسار طويل لكثير من الدول تقضيه
بين الوعود والافعال يبدو ان طريق السويد
وفنلندا اقصر لكنه ضبابي يمر بحسابات
سياسيه اضافه الى العسكريه عبد الله
الشامي الجزيره بروكسيل
غير بعيد عن اوكرانيا يتصاعد الخلاف
والامريكي الصيني والموضوع انه هناك
اتهامات تتعلق باحتمال امداد بيجين لموسكو
بالسلاح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان
لدى واشنطن معلومات تفيد بذلك ومن جانبه
قلا الامين العام لحلف الناتو
ان الحلف يرى اشارات تدعم ما تحدث عنه
بلنكن وبدورها نفت الخارجيه الصينيه
الاتهامات ووصفتها بالافتراءات بينما اكد
نائب المندوب الصيني لدى الامم المتحده
انبيجين ستعلن قريبا مبادره سياسيه لتسويه
ما سماها الازمه في اوكرانيا
اكثر فاكثر تتعزز اجواء الريبه وانعدام
الثقه بين الصين والغرب على خلفيه حرب
اوكرانيا فبيانات بيجين النافيه لتزويد
روسيا بالاسلحه تقابل بالتجاهل ولا تلقى
حتى الان اذان صاغيه لا من الولايات
المتحده ولا من حلف النيتو
وصلتنا معلومات خلال الشهور الاخيره تشير
بقوه الى ان الصين تفكر في تقديم اسلحه
الى روسيا الرئيس بايدن قال بوضوح للرئيس
الصيني خلال محادثه عبر التقنيه الفيديو
ان تقديم الصين مساعدات عسكريه الى روسيا
في الصراع باوكرانيا او اختراق العقوبات
سيمثل مشكله كبيره في العلاقات بين
الولايات المتحده والصين
بهذا التصريح يتهم بلين الصين للمره
الثالثه خلال اسبوع
باعتزامها نقل اسلحه دون تقديم ادله غير
ان صحيفه
نقلت عن مسؤولين في اداره الرئيس بايدن ان
واشنطن تدرس اصدار معلومات استخباراتيه
بشان احتمال وجود نوايا لدى الصين لنقل
اسلحه الى روسيا وبحسب الصحيفه فان بيجين
حذره من تشجيع الروس لكنها ايضا قلقه من
تداعيات فشلهم في الحرب وعليه رجحت
التقييمات الاستخباراتيه الا تشمل
المساعدات المرتقبه اسلحه متطوره وانما
ذخائره واجزاء الكترونيه يحتاجها بعض
انواع الاسلحه وردا على ذلك عاودت
الخارجيه الصينيه نفي ما سمتها الافتراءات
الامريكيه مؤكده دور
في البحث عن حل لانهاء الحرب
ما تسمى بالمعلومات الاستخباريه من الجانب
الامريكي ليست لا تكهنات ومحاولات لتشويه
سمعه الصين فمنذ اندلاع الازمه في
اوكرانيا وقفت الصين بحزم الى جانب الحوار
والسلام ولعبت دورا مسؤولا وبناء في تخفيف
الوضع وحل الازمه من خلال تعزيز محادثات
السلام بطريقه الخاصه
الاتهامات الغربيه للصين بدعم موسكو في
حربها على اوكرانيا بدات الجمعه الماضيه
على هامش ملتقى ميونخ للامن لكنها تصاعدت
بعد استقبال الرئيس الروسي لوزير الخارجيه
الصيني في موسكو
وموجها رساله الى واشنطن ضمنا كشف بوتين
عن زياره مرتقبه لنظيره الصيني واشاد
بالمستوى الرفيع الذي بلغته علاقات
البلدين لا سيما على الصعيد التجاري مركز
الدراسات الدفاعيه المتطوره في الولايات
المتحده توقع ان ترسل الصين الى روسيا
اجزاء الكترونيه لردارات الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات وذكر المركز ان بعض الشركات
الصينيه توفر المسيرات المدنيه مستغله
المساحه الرماديه بين الاغراض العسكريه
والمدنيه تقارير لا ترقى بعد الى حد
اليقين لكنها كفيله بتاجيج رجال الغربي
الصيني ودفع الازمه بين الطرفين الى
مستويات متقدمه من التصعيد
ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا الباحث في مجلس
العلاقات الخارجيه الامريكيه من بيجين
فيكتور نائب رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه
اهلا بكما معنا في الحصاد وابدا معك
يعني الحديث عن نوايا يعني بلنكن يتحدث عن
احتمال
يتحدث عن مؤشرات هل هذا كافي هل هذه ارضيه
كافيه للتصعيد في هذه المرحله
انه في الوقت الحالي للوقايه المتحده
تحاول ان تشير للصين بان عليها ان لا تقوم
بتوجيهز اي اسلحه وذخار الى روسيا لان ذلك
سيكون امرا خطيرا التوتر في العالم وهذا
كامكانيه وهذا الشيء دار الامريكيه
والولايات المتحده قامه بشكل جيد قبل حرب
اوكرانيا
والكشفت ما كان يخطط له بوتين واسبابه
وذراعيه لغزو روسيا والان يلتفت الى نفس
التعليمات
بالاعلان عن بعض معلومات استخباريه وحتى
كشف بعض معظمات استخباريه من اجل الردع
ردع الصين في هذا الوقت من تقديم اي اسلحه
الى روسيا وهذا طبعا مشان يصعد ويمدد
الحرب في اوكرانيا وهو ما لا نريده
هل هذا القلق في محله بمعنى ان الصين
اتفاقات صناعه عسكريه مع روسيا لديها يعني
تبادل تكنولوجيا كل هذا هل يعني انها
مساله وقت فقط قبل ان تمد بيجين يد العون
لحليفها الشيوعي السابق
انا الاوان لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا في
اسرع وقت ممكن ثانيا اي بلدان تقدم
السلاح لاوكرانيا انها الوقت المتحده
لنسمي الاشياء باسمائها
السارق يتهم الاخرين بالسرقه كما يقول
الصيني يجب ان لا يضلل العالم لنعرف اي
بلد يزود اوكرانيا بالسلاح ثانيا الحرب في
اوكرانيا هي لم تعد حربا بعد الان بان
روسيا واوكرانيا هي حرب الوكاله تطلع بها
الولايات المتحده اوروبا تصفيه دورها
كحاربه بالوكاله ضد روسيا علينا ان ننظر
الى جوهر هذه الحرب اما التحدث عن نوايا
او تكهنات انا لا اتوقع ابدا من اكبر عظمه
في العالم اليوم تبدا اذهب الى هذا المدى
بان
تخمن
وتتكهن وتتهم بلدان اخرى على هذا الاساس
هذه ليست دبلوماسيه هذا محظو خيال
يعني تطورت الامور
وعلى الارض ووصلت الى حد ربما معين هل
يمكن ان يدفع هذا بيجين لان تقدم فعلا
العون لموسكو في هذه المرحله هل هناك نقطه
تجد ان
ستعيد النظر فيما ترددت فيه على مدى عام
كامل
اسمحوا لي ان اقول للتاريخ لا بلد في
العالم له حق او تبرير ان يقول للصين ما
عليها ان تفعله لا تفعل ما تفعل الصين بلد
له سيادته وقدراته على اتخاذ القرار وهي
ستتخذ اي قرار وفقا لحكمه على الامور
لتفعله وما لا تفعل الصين ملتزمه بجميع
قرارات مجلس الامن بالطبع لكن لو ان اي
بلد يقرر او يصدقوا بانها اذا هذه البلدان
قررت قرارا على الصين ان تتبع ذلك هذا
جنون عليه من يستيقظوهم ليسوا
الهه ليسوا مسيطرين على كل شيء وهم ليسوا
المستبدين الديكتاتورين المطلقين للعالم
كيف يمكن لاي بلد في العالم ان تكون له
الجراه بان يقول ان لامريكا ان تملي على
الصين ما تقوم به فقط الشعب الصيني
والحكومه الصيني اريد ان انقل هذا فكره
اشرت اليها الى ديفيد والقضيه الان ان
الصين تريد تريد النوع من
الوساطه تريد المصالحه تعرض مبادره ولكن
الموقف الامريكي هنا لافت الجمهوريون
والديمقراطيون على السواء يرفضون اي
مبادره صينيه بغض النظر عن محتواها حتى
قبل ان يعرفوا محتواها ما الذي يقلقهم
ان المشكله هنا هي الولايات المتحده بل
المشكله انه من الصعب ان نعرف هل ان الصين
في موقع او يسمح لها ان تكون وسيطا لانها
ليست ليست موضوعيه في هذا فحتى قبل غزوه
اوكرانيا فان الرئيسين الروسي والصين
علاقات قويه جدا ولطالما دعمت الصين موقف
الروسي سياسيا وكانت تلقي اللوم على
النيتو وعلى الولايات المتحده بهذه الحرب
كما قدموا لروسيا الكثير من الدعم
الاقتصادي واضيف شيئا اخر ان السجن بين
لابد عليه ان يتصل هاتفيا
ليثبت انه الطرف غير منحاز في هذا النزاع
بدل الذهاب الى موسكو وانا التخطيط زياره
الى الى هناك الخطه لزياره موسكو ولكن
عليه ان يتصل
بنظرائه الاوكرانيين والنعم نقطه اخرى نعم
الولايات المتحده تقدم اسلحه لاوكرانيا
طبعا تفعل ذلك هناك معتدي واحد هنا هو وهو
روسيا بوتين هو يتدافع عن سيادتها وان
الصين اكثر من اي بلد في العالم تتحدث عن
اهميه السياده البلدان واحترامي في هذا
ولكن هنا لدينا انتهاك واضح
لسياده بلد من على يد بلد اخر ولايك
المتحده الساعه ذلك البلد المضطر لمقاطعتك
اعذرني
الباحث في مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه
الامريكيه والزميل السابق في المعهد
الامريكي في تايوان واشكر ايضا فيكتور
نائب رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه من ديجين
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
اتهام مركز الشهاب لحقوق الانسان سلطات
المصريه بارتكاب انتهاكات موسعه ضد
المعتقلين في داخل سجن بدر ثلاثه وقال
المركز الحقوقيه ان السلطات المصريه تتعنت
منذ سبعه اعوام في منع الاهالي من زياره
ذويهم المعتقلين محذرا من ان عددا من
المعتقلين اقدم على الانتحار نتيجه
المعامله السيئه واضاف المركز الحقوقيه ان
معتقلين داخل السجن بداوا اضرابا احتجاجا
على ظروف اعتقالهم السيئه الامر الذي
واجهته اداره السجن بالمزيد من التعسف
والعنف واكد المركز الحقوقي ان المرشد
العام لجماعه الاخوان دخل في اضراب كلي
بسبب المعامله السيئه من قبل اداره السجن
له وعدم الاستجابه له في الذهاب للمستشفى
ومنعه من حضور الجلسات امام النيابه وكان
تقرير لوكاله رويتر سلطه الضوء على ما
وصفها بانتهاكات حقوق الانسان في سجن بدر
واشار الى انه يتم حرمان النزلاء من
الرعايه صحيه ويتم اخضاعهم لمعامله عقابيه
تشمل العزل
ومعنى الان من فيينا باربرا
ترامبث وهي عضو مجلس اداره منتدى التعبير
العالمي والباحثه في المعهد الدولي
للصحافه سيده ريان في اهلا بك في الحصاد
هذا التحقيق في النهايه يعني هناك تحققت
تحقيقات اخرى وهناك مراكز اخرى حقوقيه
ذهبت الى النفس
الخلاصه ولكن في النهايه الامر مستمر ما
الذي يمكن فعله
للضغط على الحكومه المصريه لانهاء هذا
الموقف
مع الاسف الامر في غايه الصعوبه وان
الكثير منظمات في العالم بما في ذلك
معهد الصحافه الدوليه يحاول منذ سنوات
للضغط على السلطات المصريه للتاكد من
قيامهم باحترام حكم القانون احترام هذه
المبادئ وهذه الالتزامات التي وقعوا عليها
وبشكل خاص
احترام مبدا ان الصحفي لديه حق بالحصول
على العداله وكما قلت فان قضيه عبد اللطيف
وابراهيم وهم ليسوا دماء كثير من الصحفيين
الاخرين في السجون واضافه الى
ناشطين ومثلون اخرين من مجتمع المدني وان
نظام العداله لا يمكن الوثوق به اطلاقا
وبالتالي الامكانيه الوحيده لدينا ان
نواصل بدل الضغوط ومحاوله الضغط على
الحكومات التي اي نوع من الضغوط يعني ما
نسمعه حتى الان مجرد ادانات هل هناك شيء
عملي او اجراء يمكن اتخذه
في الواقع كما تعلمون القانون الدولي يعمل
بطريقه انه لا يمكن لا يمكن تنفيذه فهناك
تطبيقي
وبالتالي فان الاذانات
هي اكثر ما يمكن القيام به في مثل هذا
الوضع وان غنى شاهدنا الكثير مثل هذه
الادانات من قبل مجلس حقوق الانسان
ومؤسسات دوليه كثيره ولكن مع الاسف ليس
هناك اي وسيله والطريقه للتاكد بشكل مباشر
من قيام الحكومه باحترام حقوق الانسان او
حكم القانون
اشكركون فيه عضو مجلس اداره منتدى التعبير
العالمي والباحثه في المعهد الدولي
للصحافه من فيينا
جددت محكمه مصريه حبس الصحفيين بالجزيره
مباشر هشام عبد العزيز وبهاء ابراهيم
ليتجاوز حبسهما ثلاث سنوات دون محاكمه
وكانت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه اصدرت بيانا
دعت فيه للافراج الفوري عن بهاء الدين
ابراهيم وزميليه المعتقلين في مصر
عفوا وقالت في بيانها ان الزميل بهاء
الدين ابراهيم المنتج في قناه الجزيره
مباشر اكمل ثلاث سنوات في السجون المصريه
واشارت الى تعرض الزميل بهاء الدين
لانتهاكات قانونيه مستمره منها الاخفاء
القصري والتعذيب الكهرباء والحبس
الانفرادي
وعربت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه عن قلقها
الشديد على سلامه الزميل بهاء الدين
ابراهيم وزميليه هشام عبد العزيز وربيع
الشيخ المحتجزين كذلك دون محاكمه في
زنازين تفتقر لابسط شروط الصحه والنظافه
ودعت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه في بيانها كل
الهيئات المعنيه بحريه الصحافه والمنظمات
الحقوقيه في العالم الى الوقوف مع الزميل
بهاء الدين ابراهيم وغيره من الصحفيين
المسجونين في مصر والمطالبه باطلاق سراحهم
فورا
الان الى الرياضه مع معز بولحيه
[موسيقى]
ارحب بكم نسال هذه الجوله باخر اخبار
الدوري الاوروبي مواجهه كبرى اوشكت على
النهايه بين مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزي
وظيفه برشلونه الاسباني دوري خروج المغلوب
المؤهل لدور 16 من المسابقه الاوروبيه
المباراه اذا في دقائقها الاخيره ومانشستر
يونايتد يتقدم بهدفين لهدف نذكر بانه
مباراه الذهاب بين الفريقين كانت قد انتهت
بهدفين
لمثلهما وسنعود ان شاء الله
اواخر هذه الاطلاله
لنمدكم بجديد وتطورات هذه المواجهه
المستمره
في ذلك الاطار سجل نجم الارجنتيني اخر دي
ماريا ثلاثيه ليقود يوفنتوس الايطالي
لبلوغ دور 16 من مسابقه الدوري الاوروبي
على حساب مستضيف الفرنسي وذلك في واحده من
ابرز مباريات اياب دوري خروج المغلوب
فريق نانتي الفرنسي وضيفه يوفنتوس
الايطالي يمتلكان نفس الحظوظ لبلوغ دور 16
من المسابقه القاريه بعد نهايه مباراه
الذهاب بالتعادل فريق السيده العجوز لم
يضيع الكثير من الوقت وتقدم بهدف ملعوب
احرزه الارجنتيني انقل دي ماريا تحت انظار
اساطير نانت السابقين
لام خالد ماريا جول يا له من جول ويا له
من دي ماريا ويا له من انخل
سحر دي ماريا وامكانته الخاصه كانت سببا
مباشرا في حصول فريقه يوفنتوس على ركله
جزاء وطرد على اثرها نيكولاس بالوا مدافع
نانت وترجمها دي ماريا الى هدف ثاني
[موسيقى]
لليوفي
التقدم في النتيجه منح يوفنتوس افضليه
واضحه وكان فيليب كوستتش قريبا من اضافه
هدف ثالث لولا القائم
النقص العددي حاول اليوفي استغلاله ونجح
دي ماريا في تسجيل هدف ثالث مسجلاله بعد
الرجوع لتقنيه الفيديو المساعد
دخلت دخلت لا تسافر صارت النتيجه
وحاول المصري مصطفى محمد حفظ ماء وجه
فريقه نانت بهدف شرفي لكن الحارس تشيزني
تصدى لكرته فانتهت المباراه بتاهل منطقيا
ليوفنتوس في ليله تالق فيها نجمه دي ماريا
البرتغالي لدوره 16 من الدوري الاوروبي
تغلب على مضيف الدنماركي باربعه اهداف دون
مقابل الروبواني
سجل هدف السابق لسبورتينغ في الدقيقه
الحاديه والعشرين
واضاف بيدرو الهدف الثاني للفريق
البرتغالي في الدقيقه الخمسين
هو من اضاف ايضا هدفا اخر في شباك
على ثالث اهداف فريقه ومسجلا ثنائيه شخصيه
عند الدقيقه 77 اما رابع اهداف سبورتينغ
فسجله اللاعب
خطا
في شباك فريقه في الدقيقه 85 كانت مباراه
الذهاب في لشبونه قد انتهت بالتعادل بهدف
من الجانبين
وايضا عبر اشبيليه الاسباني لدور 16 رغم
خسارته في ضيافه الهولندي بهدفين مقابل
سجلها في الدقيقه 77
في الوقت بديل الضائعه لكن بطاقه التاهل
ذهبت لشبيليا الذي استفاد من فوزه على
ملعبه في مباراه الذهاب بثلاثيه نظيفه
في ذات الدور ايضا تاهل بايرن ليفركوزن
الالماني بفوز على مستضيف موناكو
بعد التعادل بخمسه اهداف لمثلها في مجموعه
مباراتي الذهاب والاياب منح فلوريان
التقدم لمصلحه باير ليفربول في الدقيقه
الثالثه عشره وادرك وسام بن يدر تعادل
لفريق الاماره بعد بسته دقائق من ركله
جزاء اضاف الارجنتيني
هدفا ثانيا للضيوف عند الدقيقه الحادي
والعشرين سجل امين عدلي الثالث اهدافي
في الدقيقه الثالثه
والخمسين من عمر المباراه وقبل ست دقائق
على نهايه الوقت الاصلي سجل بريل امبولو
والهدف الثاني
لموناكون
بعد ان تعادلت نتيجه
ذهابا وايابا بخمسه اهداف من الجانبين ولم
تتغير في الشوطين الاضافيين ليتم الاحتكام
لركلات الترجيح فحسمها ليفربول
وحجز بالتالي مكانا في ثمن النهائي
اوروبيه نعلنا ايضا المدافع الاسبانيه
المخادره من العمر 36 عاما اعلن اعتزال
اللعب دوليا راموس خادم 180 مباراه دوليه
سجل خلال 23 هدفا كانت ابرز انجازاتها
المساهمه في فوز الاروخا بكاس امم اوروبا
في نسختي 2008
و2012 ال شرف التتويجي بمونديالي 2010 في
جنوب افريقيا
اسيويه ان الان باتت حيل القطريه ولا
المتاهلين لنصف نهائي دوري ابطال اسيا
بفوز على الشباب السعودي بهدفين لهدف في
ربع النهائي على ملعب الثمامه في الدوحه
ايضا انتظرت حيل حتى دقيقه السابعه
والسبعين ليفتتح التسجيل عبر الكيني مايكل
الذي عاد واضاف الهدف الثاني لفريقه في
الدقيقه الخامسه اما هدف الشباب الوحيد في
المباراه فسجله سعيد الربيعي في اللحظات
الاخيره من زمن هذه المواجهه
ومنح موسى ماريجا الهلال السعودي بطاقه
العبور للمربع الذهبي بهدف حاسم امام
فولاذ الايراني في المباراه التي اقيمت
على ملعب الجنوبي في الوكره
[تصفيق]
افريقيا الان تعادل حسب التعادل مواجهات
الكونغو امام اوغندا بهدفين ضمن المجموعه
الثانيه لكاس امم افريقيا للشباب تحت 20
عاما المقامه حاليا في مصر
التقدم للكونغو في الدقيقه السادسه ادرك
سيمانيا التعادلات لاوغندا بعدها بخمس
دقائق
هدف التعادل واضاف سعيدي مانيانجا هدفا
ثانيا لاوغندا عند الدقيقه 33
وخطف موبلي هدف التعادل للكونغو في
الدقيقه الثانيه
المنتخبين راسياهما لاربع نقاط في هذه
المجموعه
في ذات المجموعه غلبان منتخب جنوب السودان
على منتخب افريقيا الوسطى بهدف دون مقابل
سجلهم ماري في الدقيقه الثانيه من ركله
جزاء رفع منتخب بلاده ظن رصيده الى ثلاث
نقاط في المركز
بعيدا عن كره القدم ودع الروسيه
المصنف اولا منافسه بطوله قطر للتنس من
ربع النهائي خسارته امام تشيكي ياري تشيكا
بمجموعتين لواحده الاولى بسته اشواط
لاربعه لكنه خسر الثانيه والثالثه باربعه
يتاهل تشيكا لنصف النهائي في هذه البطوله
المقامه في الدوحه
ووصول الى اول نصف نهائي هنا في نصف نهائي
البريطانيا
بمجموعتين لواحده اربعه
لشوطين في المجموعه الاخيره
قبل الختام لا باس ان نذكر بجديد مباراه
مانشستر يونايتد وبرشلونه بالطبع لحد الان
المباراه مستمره في لحظاتها الاخيره نتيجه
تشير الى تقدم مانشستر يونايتد بهدفين
لهدف وحيد نتابع مع بعض اهداف هذه
المباراه الى حد
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه مطالب باله
[تصفيق]
دف
احمر من البدايات فسخ وعا
ود من برشلونه
[تصفيق]
تابعنا الاهداف الثلاثه وهي اهداف
المباراه التي انتهت الان حاليا وبالتالي
تاهل مانشستر يونايتد الى الدور المقبل من
الدوري الاوروبي بهذا الخبر ناتي الى
الختام الجوله الرياضيه الان الى ليله
[موسيقى]
شكرا
قبل ان ننهي الحصاد نتوقف عند هذه اللحظات
الهامه التي اثرت على العالم برمته قبل
عام كامل بدات حرب القت بظلالها على الشرق
والغرب قتلت اناسا شردت اخرين وهددت غذاء
العالم برمته لتفاقم ازمه الجوع فصول
كثيره فرضتها الحرب في اوكرانيا فصول لا
تذكرنا الى بمدى مشاعه الحرب اي حرب كانت
انتهى الحصاد الليله تصبحون على سلام
[موسيقى]
الحكم حدوده يراقبه المشرع يحاسبه القضاء
ويكشفه الاعلام وعندما تخفق كل هذه
السلطات لابد من سلطه فوقها انتم فوق
السلطه اليوم في السابعه والنصف مساء
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اغلقت عاصفه شتويه قويه
طرق سريعه بين الولايات من اريزونا الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه العاصفه
الثلجيه اجتاحت منطقه سهول الشماليه
والغرب الاوسط الامريكيه متسببه في هبات
رياحا عاتيا وتساقط كفيفا للثلوج حاصرت
العاصفه سائق السيارات داخل سياراتهم
اجبرت مئه المدارس على الاغلاق في ذاكوتا
وكلورادو ويومينغ قطعت الكهرباء عن مئات
الالف من الاشخاص وتسببت بالغاء رحله جويه
داخليه وخارجيه واحده من اكثر المناطق
تضررا في الغرب الاوسط الامريكي كانت من
نابوليس حيث اعلن المسؤولون المحليون حاله
الطوارئ فيها هذا هو من المتوقع ان تضرب
درجات الحراره المنخفضه ورياح العاتيه
والثلوج الكثيفه والجليد الخطير معظم
انحاء الولايات حتى نهايه الاسبوع على
الاقل الارصاد الجويه الامريكيه توقعت
استمرار العاصفه حتى مطلع الاسبوع القادم
في كاليفورنيا وقد تم بالفعل اصدار تحضير
الاول من نواهي منذ عقود من عاصفه ثلجيه
متوقعه في جنوب كاليفورنيا يقول الخبراء
ان زياده تواتر قوه مثل هذه العواصف التي
تتخللها درجات حراره شديده الارتفاع
ونوبات الجفاف هي حتما من اعراض تغير
المناخه بالتالي مشاهدينا يخضع اكثر من 50
مليون امريكي لتحضيرات الطقس الشتوي السيء
مع تحرك العاصفه عبر رقعه واسعه من غربي
وشمال الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ووصولا
الى الشرق خدمه الطقس الوطنيه الامريكيه
قالت انه من المتوقع تساقط ثلوج تصل الى
60 سم ووصول سرعه الرياح الى 100 كم في
الساعه خلال الساعات القادمه درجه الحراره
تسجل دون صفر متوقعه مساء
تصل الى خمسه عشره درجه مئويه تحت
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
في داخل مدينه الناصر عندما هبطت الطائره
في اتجاه الريح بها الى داخل البحر
مؤامره مدبره
وفوج بها ولكن
المهبض وصوله يعني ما اتوقع وكان الهواء
شديد جدا صدمه كده فعلا يتعامل من
المستحيل وفعلا في صندوق اسود والحاجات دي
كلها ما ظهروها من ناحيه سياسيا اختيارات
السياسيه تتم لافراد لكنها مجموعه كبيره
وبكل سياسيه لا يستطيع نظام ان يتحمل
الجريمه
الزبير محمد صالح اليوم في العاشره وخمس
دقائق مساء بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]